[inaudible]
so a few weeks ago,
I told you the story of the Tokyo
Olympics in 2020 and all the problems
that they're facing,
any of the Olympic Games are one of the
most expensive events that a city can
host.
Nonetheless,
usually city hauls go crazy to get a
chance to organize the limbics.
Usually they always have the support of
their national governments and their
citizens.
In fact,
each time they'd make a survey,
most of the people are happy about
hosting the Olympic Games.
The main opinion is that's an event.
It's lengthy.
Olympics brings a lot of good into the
country.
It increases tourism.
The host city gets renovators and the
country becomes fashionable attracting
investors and businessmen from all over
the world.
Well,
if you've seen our video about Tokyo,
you know that this isn't exactly true.
In fact,
the Olympics can create big problems in
Japan,
might end up going bankrupt from going
so far over budget.
In fact,
we can say that is a big debate about
whether it's goods or bad.
It's a host,
the Olympic Games,
and guess what?
The Olympic excitements is not exactly
having its best hour until 2012 each
time the International Olympic Committee
met to choose the next host city.
There were around five candidates.
However,
the 2024 games had just two candidates,
Los Angeles and Paris.
Yes.
Many capitals like boot of hash or Rome
retired their bid at the last minute and
others like Hamburg and Germany organize
a referendum or citizens voted against
hosting the Olympics.
Yes,
you heard that right?
There is the general disappointments
about the Olympics and this might be a
big problem for the International
Olympic Committee if nobody wants to
host.
I mean what could happen to the future
of the Olympic Games and the bigger
question of course is,
well,
is this the end of the Olympics spirits?
So what could we do to keep the Olympic
flame burning?
Well,
today we're going to answer those
questions,
but before we do that is take a look
back at the history.
Great.
Vic Breakfast.
I'm sure that every one of you knows
that the Olympic Games work she did in
ancient Greece,
but the truth is that the muzzle
Olympics has nothing to do with Mount
Olympus.
It really started in the 1896 with a
French born baron named Pierre to cook a
tall,
along with a Greek man named evangelist
Zapper.
They convince the Greek government to
organize some games the same way that
the ancient Greeks sat back then,
nationalism was high in Greece,
so everything that helps to inflame the
national pride was seen as a good idea
by the government.
This is how the first modern Olympics
we're organized in Athens.
Nonetheless,
he had to keep,
it all had bigger plans than simple
nationalist propaganda.
This could be an international events.
What's in order to achieve this?
The host city had to rotate.
This is how the International Olympic
Committee also known as I oh c was born.
The IOC is an organization responsible
for ensuring that every four years we
have the winter Olympics,
the summer Olympics,
and the Paralympics.
Put it another way.
This committee's mission is to promote
sports and tolerance among nations.
And this was a pretty wonderful idea,
but do hold on for just a second because
we are just getting started with our
story.
The first Olympic Games were pretty
modest events that were organized next
to international exhibitions,
but things really changed in the year
okay.
As you know,
back then,
Nazi Germany,
well,
they were about to start their world
conquest to this end is they needed to
improve that image abroad and is the
idea of wrapping themselves with the
flag of sports excellence and tolerance
between nations sounded like heaven to
the ears of adult headlock and this is
why the Bellin Olympic Games in 1936
became the first Olympic super reduction
in history.
It cost more than 30 million US dollars
at the time,
and that was an insane amount of money
back in the day.
The precedent for hosted cities
overspending on the Olympic Games while
it all came from Nazi Germany.
Okay.
But the first big economic catastrophe,
well that came many years later with the
Montreal Olympics in 1976
those games ended up costing eight times
more than the initial budget and they
had lasting financial consequences.
Canada didn't finish paying the debt in
incurred to finance those games until
2006 they even had to create a new
special tax for tobacco in order to
cover the costs.
I'm the story here.
It's really simple.
I mean there were lots of cities who
want to host the Olympics,
but first they need to be chosen by the
IOC.
And as you can imagine,
the more you are willing to spend,
the higher your chances of winning the
bid.
And listen,
I can probably guess what you're
thinking right now.
Why is money that's important to the
International Olympic Committee?
Do you know what I mean?
Didn't we just say that what matters
here is the tolerance,
the excellence and the sports.
Well,
yeah,
you are right,
but the budget is not the only element
that the IOC takes into account when it
chooses a host sissy.
There are plenty of other factors that
they need to keep in mind.
Okay.
Bribery scandal threatens to shrink 2002
Winter Games,
man,
that is just one example.
According to the AISC manual,
each time they visit one candidate city,
the town hall must pay for a four or
five star hotel and international
breakfast and luxury private cars for
each of their members.
And yes,
this is actually specified in the
guidelines and listen,
according to recent investigations,
the parties that are held to entertain
the IOC members would pretty much make
Berlusconi's orgies look like Sunday
mass.
All right,
so you might think that with that last
statement,
I'm exaggerating a little,
but really I,
I
no
to IOC members accepted offers of
prostitution from the Amsterdam
Committee that bid for the 1992 summer
games.
As you can see,
it's not like the IOC members live like
rockstars.
Indeed,
I would say that rock stars who wished
they lived like IOC members.
Well,
do you know what the best parts of all
of this as well,
their organization makes millions of
dollars every year,
but they aren't even registered as a
company.
The IOC is technically a nonprofit
organization headquartered in
Switzerland.
All right,
so what does that actually mean?
Well,
essentially it means that they don't
need to pay taxes and they can use all
kinds of strategies.
Do you honey their accounting book?
Well,
it essentially means that they don't
need to pay taxes and they can use all
kinds of strategies.
Do you hype their accounting books?
Yeah.
Now you may remember that we previously
did a video about e sports where we
talked about Formula One Formula One.
While that's a publicly traded company,
and that's why on visual politic we
could give you accurate numbers for how
much money they make.
With the Olympics.
It's far,
far more difficult.
You can make estimations based on how
much they charge for the broadcasting
rights are.
That's,
that's pretty much it.
So now you may be wondering,
why am I sticking quite so much on how
much money the IOC actually makes look
vast?
Because when somebody has a good income
and almost no spending,
I mean don't forget that the Games are
pretty much paid almost entirely by
local governments.
Well.
Then you can invest in things like this.
Astroturfing is the practice of masking
the sponsors of a message or
organization.
For example,
political advertising,
religious or public relations to make it
appear as though it originates from and
is supported by grassroots participants.
In other words,
you can pay for things like the Olympic
studies centers,
which have a presence in several
universities all around the globe.
That job is basically to produce
academic research to prove with
scientific research and data that
hosting the Olympics is as good as
winning the lottery.
But listen,
this is not the end of the story here.
I told you some of the reasons why a
city is chosen to host the Olympic,
but this is still not the end of our
story today.
I told you some of the reasons
previously why a city would be chosen to
host the Olympics.
Well,
another one is what they call the
Olympic feeling among the citizens.
This means how much people in the city
or country are actually in favor of
hosting the Games.
So if you're watching this video from
London,
you probably have some idea of what I'm
talking about.
I mean,
all of a sudden the local media is
talking about it,
your friends,
but the Olympic logo on their facebook
profile picture,
and it's almost impossible.
Find critics on any talk show.
I mean,
it's really in the interest of the
entire governments and the sponsors to
silence all of the discordant voices.
So this is probably why this happens.
And then,
I mean,
what's the conclusion we can draw from
all of this?
Well,
in a city like Madrid,
more than 85% of citizens wanted the
Olympic Games according to a survey.
And a similar thing happens in Tokyo and
in pretty much any other host city.
So all of this explains partly the rush
to organize the Olympics that pretty
much any cost.
Japan has already announced that they
were spending over 20 billion United
States dollars for that Tokyo Olympics
in 2020 Rio de Janeiro in 2012 costs
more than $12 billion for the Brazilian
taxpayer.
And then there's grease.
I mean,
that's still paying their debts from
Athens.
And 2004 nonetheless though things they
aren't changing.
Sure.
Is there any future for the Olympics?
As we said before,
in the nineties and the first decade of
this century,
anytime the IOC and match,
there were around five candidate cities.
Nonetheless in the vote for the Olympics
in 2020 the one that Tokyo one there
were just three candidates in the last
two beds for the Olympics.
2024 and 2028 there wasn't even a single
vote because there was only one
candidate city,
Los Angeles in one case,
and Paris in the other cities like Rome,
Budapest in Stockholm,
which once bid for the Olympics have
already simply retired from the race
bay.
Just don't think it's worth
money.
And to all of those economists who were
once silenced while they're starting to
appear in the media.
Meanwhile,
the An indie games,
sir losing a lot of their appeal for
audiences,
there are less and less viewers every
time it runs.
Platforms like Netflix,
HBO,
or even indeed Youtube are becoming big
competition for traditional television.
This means that by the time it Tokyo
2020 years health,
many of you will be watching a TV show
or official politic video instead of the
synchronized swimming competition.
And so well now you might be wondering,
well how did the International Olympic
Committee react to this?
Well,
the answer is probably going to
disappoint you,
but I see it.
Yeah.
Ioc Agenda 2020 allows the Olympics in
different host countries.
I mean,
I'm not saying this is a bad idea,
but it does make little sense if your
goal is to reduce wasted money when
organizing the Olympic Games.
I mean,
yeah,
it is good now that the spending could
be divided among the taxpayers have two
different countries,
but then also have twice as many venues
as before.
So in other words,
it's not actually that great of an idea.
Now,
wait just a second here because this is
not the only proposal you see lately.
There's a movement that suggesting
something a bit more revolutionary.
They wanted to get rid of city rotation.
This would mean that the Olympic Games
would always be organized in the same
city this way,
which is neat to buy one stadium and one
Olympic villa that could be reused every
single time.
Some economists like Andrew's Marlis
suggest Los Angeles is the perfect city
to become the eternal Olympic host.
It's big enough they have an
international airport and they can
receive all the tourists and they also
have a pretty solid media industry.
The solution has a problem.
If there is no competition among cities
to host the Olympics and the IOC would
lose its negotiating leverage,
be no incentive to bribe or provide
luxury to IOC leaders and sooner or
later Los Angeles or some other city
that would become the permanent host
would start demanding things like a
greater share of the money from the
broadcasting.
Right.
So now the question comes around too.
Do you think the International Olympic
Committee,
we'll find an alternative solution to
get back their lost prestige or perhaps
we will see the ends of the Olympic
Games as we know it's,
well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below.
Meanwhile,
if you want to know more about the Tokyo
Olympics in 2020 and all of the troubles
they are creating in Japan,
do you click here to see that video?
Also,
please
do
visit
our
friends@thereconsidermediapodcastatreconsidermedia.com
this is the podcast that provided the
vocals in this video that we're not mine
and I forgot that we published brand new
videos just like this every Monday and
Thursday.
So hit that subscribe button and you
won't miss a post nos.
If you liked this video,
give us a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
I'll forget to check out the reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com.